all right honey yes honey where'd you
grow up were you from originally I'm
from Compton California yep then you
grew up with both your parents yes tell
me about your childhood yet there well
my childhood is like bad but like I
don't like that gets me ball you know in
what ways was it bad like I basically
been through sexual abuse physical
mentally emotional connect from your
parents from both my parents what guy
stuff was going on uh like my dad would
like touch me inappropriately when my
mom wasn't there
and my mom would like hit me and [ __ ]
upside my head did you ever tell anybody
about this going here no I haven't so
your whole I'm 17 17 and how long you
been on the street I've done this day
for three years so 14 did you finish
high school
no did you go to high school at all yes
I did how many years did you get home -
- so now you're living we're here on
this street I'm on the street in a tent
yes
and so what are you doing to support
yourself
I basically sell my body to make money
in [ __ ] to support myself to give me
food and should I need clothes and [ __ ]
so you just pick up guys on the street
yeah and are using any of the drugs that
are out here yes I you crystal meth
crystal meth
yes what age were you when you first
started using drugs thirteen thirteen
mm-hmm and do you think
do you have any contact with your family
at all no when's the last time you spoke
to your parents they're dead they're
dead
mm-hmm how'd you lose your parents my
dad got shot because my dad was
affiliated and my mom she died of
natural causes
when you say natural causes like what
like she was she was old she died of
natural causes
so you're dead when you say affiliated
it means he wasn't he was a gang member
is he Mexican black right so your
daddy's boy yes he's my stepdad stepdad
okay and do you have any siblings no
you'd only travel yes give any
grandparents uncle no I have two kids
well you have two children I have your
honor yes to a daughter in the son my
daughter died two days ago my son's in
the hospital sick right now what did
your daughter die she had the corona she
caught the Cologne and died mm-hmm and
are you worried about catching it or not
were you in her life
yes I was in her life but her her dad he
died two years before her third birthday
so when she contracted coronavirus how
long ago was that
well she caught it a month ago but they
they finally told me she died two days
ago my mom my mom she called me my
stepmom she called me and she told me my
daughter was dead
how do you feel about that I feel really
hopeless right now because she was she
was she was only they knows keeping me
motivated she was the only thing that
they that won't bring me back to old
life I used to live so you have no
family no I don't and your daughter
passed away and your son he's sick he's
sick what is he sick with
they say he has an amusement in my
section he's in the hospital right now
yep
do you visit nah go to who takes carrier
who took carrier to children my stepmom
so you're not really in the kids lives
not no more
so we're we're what are you hoping to do
here you're 17 you're living on the
street you're using crystal meth you've
lost touch with your kids you've lost
one of your kids and your parents like
to be honest I really don't like how I
was raised and where I was raised that
and what I am today I'm trying to change
but it's gonna be hard for me I just
need the right help and the right people
by my side what do you think you need
therapy therapy rehab to go back to
college and finish high school finish
high school go back then go to college
get my own apartment basically say go
good goals I said do the [ __ ] I do right
now so you're picking up guys how often
do you do that every day every day
they're done here on Skid Row you get
all kinds of people right yes stories
about that no I don't have no stories
because I ain't proud of what I'm doing
but nobody gives you a hard time they do
that's right that's what I'm talking
about stories like what kind of bad
things have happened to you well
basically there was this one trick that
I did and he took me to his hotel room
and basically he forced me to have sex
with him and when I tried to run off he
grabbed me by my hair and started
hitting me in my face and I had to call
one of my homeboys for my set to come
and pick me up and my homeboys locked up
right now because he smashed his head in
with the hammer
did you kill or is he killed them my
homeboys doing life right now you've
been arrested for anyone yes I have I've
been arrested for a robbery battery
prostitution drug dealing and false ID
and false identification when the police
discover that you're underage do they do
anything about that do they treat you
differently yeah they did they did is
there anywhere they can take you or they
just set you free
they just set me free I did my time I
did four months in jail and I got out
do you have any I mean do you get
hopeless sometimes you get depressed yes
I do I would think your your history and
what's going on in your life right now
would ya people think I'm crazy because
what I've been through and how I react
to it you know what's the hardest part
of your life
well now lost my daughter well that dam
is like two days ago yeah
you'd be going to a funeral or something
like that holy [ __ ]
it's just three do you have any friends
honey no anybody you trust in your life
yeah people for my sake you're setting
your gang yeah my game and your gang is
a black gang of an Hispanic gang black
okay from Compton not Swann family Blake
what do you wish had been different
about your childhood I wish I could have
grew up differently then to grow up to
be how I am now
can you see the living down here on the
street is probably going to keep you
from getting high school you know it is
yeah you hoping to you're trying to get
out of here I'm trying you have nobody
to know it's no support system right no
people ain't say with people and the
people who you think they are so living
on the street since you're 14 what kind
of things have happened to you just from
being homeless
I've been molested I've been gang-raped
before started using crystal and
basically [ __ ] up my life doing this
[ __ ] that I'm doing now and losing my
daughter makes me think about why I have
a purpose in the world
what kind of thoughts go through your
head sometimes do you get you get
suicidal or like that sometimes no I
don't get suicidal I just get the press
and I just think about all the people
are lost what I could have done to
prevent what happened to me what do you
think you could have done I don't know I
wish I could just grow up and not be the
person I am right now yeah you never had
much of a chance
nope
what was your daughter's name coral in
it what's your son's name
Mike hell will you be visiting your son
while he's in the hospital
nah they won't let me
they were late why is that because all
I'm doing right now
what do you think would help you the
most right now
I'm just hoping that I will give me
another chance to be there for myself in
my mom
all right honey well thank you for
talking with me you're welcome
yeah you definitely could use a break
couldn't you okay
you
you